abone ol
ben kendi canıma hayat bize araba olsun
çalışması
bu çalıştığı zaman ben sana ne oldu
böyle de anneanne Sizin var öyle yani
ne yapıyorsun Nasıl oldun nasıl
kalınlaştırılır çabuk bilmiyorum da
numaran olsa ne yaptın bakayım çok güzel
olacak Annem hayır hayır gittim ama ama
ama ama ama ama
[Müzik]
o zaman lazım hiçbir anlamı yok mutlu
olacağım verdiniz mi anne bayramın 3
Şu an neredesin aracı Ben öyle bir şey
yılların uygun alacağım çıkacağım
havanın başladın mı
bu buluşu böyle oluyor hangisi oluyor
vallahi aşkım Kendine iyi bak Her şey
için sana nasıl değil Nasıl ama bizim
bu insanlar Aşkın sözleri önü şu onu
bekliyoruz nasıl yapıyorsunuz Yemek oldu
var o da takdir var mı
[Müzik]
ben sana şimdi şu anda almış sana bir
zararı olur mu
çok güldüm diğer Elimizin araba Zaten iş
yok mu
[Müzik]
yok aramadım arayacağım Sana bir şey
olmasın sizin de
[Müzik]
Ben sana diyorum öyle Bunları kırıp Biz
git olmaz mı
ama biz konuşalım oğlum çocuğum bir
şekilde çıkmam lazım mı
Ben senden şimdi varsa şimdi size
[Müzik]
geliyor bir oyuncak isteyecektim olacak
böyle
bu sabah oldu 14 15 ve o
abone ol
Ben sana bir şey diyeceğim Benim geliyor
falan her şey daha olsun şunu fark ettim
Ben okulda almış olmuş
o çalışırken 2013'te amcalarda şimdi
sözünden ama güzel olmuş şu an hayatımız
Olsun bu da bilmiyorum Bir sürü şey
kalmış sana ayarlayayım mı
[Müzik]
o zaman da herkese anlamak için de
ezeyim iPhone'un üç tane hemen lazım ve
Amin inşallah tiyatro değiştirmesine
neden sizi söylemek üzerinden senin de
[Müzik]
da dediğimizi verebilirsiniz ama bunu
evime getirildi Aslında bu gülüşüne
nasıl elbise mi
[Müzik]
bu vardır Bu olursunuz ben sana kendine
güvensizlik almamız gerekiyor bak biz
ona uzun cezayı beni yapmış Başka bir
şey değil aslında Eğer Sizler Bence
çalışacaksınız da
[Müzik]
da anladığınız göstermemiz lazım olarak
sadece eczane uzaması davranmamız
gerektiğini lazım bir şey yani şöyle
çıkarsanız o
[Müzik]
ne olacak mı daha öyle Namet yaptığınız
şeye karşı daha var şimdi kalbinde
azaltıyor yaptığı diğerleri ise her
zaman karşısında durmuştur sizin
hayatınız beslenme hayatınızda
ettirmeyiniz İsmail Şahin ya
[Alkış]